let's say that a global recession does
occur where can investors hide what do
they do with their portfolios in order
to be able to protect themselves in a
recessionary period like this
well again if the recessionary period is
followed by inflation which is how
governments
try to stimulate economies in recession
they run deficits and their central
banks print money then it's a hedge
against inflation is what you need so
you need real things like i said
commodities precious metals
companies that own real assets
that can raise their prices without you
know destroying their market
the same things that i've i've been
describing but i don't think it's going
to be a global recession i mean i think
there will be economies in recession uh
maybe some of the developed economies
that have a lot of debt but i think
emerging markets uh could actually enjoy
a boom as developed markets are enjoying
a bust uh you know they have a lot more
productivity uh they don't have the debt
they don't have uh the older populations
depended on on government uh money
uh so i think you can have a dynamic
where you have recession or very slow
growth in you know the developed
economies that have been doing all the
qe and have had artificially low
interest rates but then the emerging
markets are you know really pick up the
slack especially if their currencies
appreciate significantly and that gives
their consumers more purchasing power if
that results in better inflows of
capital into those economies to escape
the stagflationary economies of more
developed countries and especially if
the dollar loses its uh role as the
reserve currency which is clearly in
jeopardy right now and we've placed it
in greater jeopardy uh with the
sanctions on russia and driving russia
and china closer together maybe even
pulling india into the mix and pissing
off a lot of people and reminding a lot
of people of the dangers of holding
dollars as a reserve and the the
extraordinary
power that is given to the us uh by
virtue of its ability to sanction
anybody it wants if it disagrees with
what they're doing
um you know not that i agree with what
putin is doing and it doesn't even
matter it's just that every country
that's a sovereign government knows that
it may do something one day that the
united states doesn't like
you know i'm sure the united states does
stuff that a lot of other countries
don't like but they can't sanction us
because it's our currency everybody's
using but the ultimate sanction is to
stop using our currency
because then what good is it because
then the dollar is just worth what we
produce and we don't produce much i mean
i mean in aggregate look at our trade
deficits uh we have a deficit of over a
hundred billion dollars a month that is
enormous
what is the most asymmetric bet that you
have in your portfolio right now is it
an equity or something else that you're
like look this is the thing that i ha i
believe has the most upside
those that's my mining stocks
you know my my
maybe my silver mining stocks and junior
mining stocks i mean the ones that we
own in the euro pacific gold fund or the
separate accounts that are managed by
adrian day or my own personal account i
mean i think those are the stocks
that could not only be 10 baggers but 50
100 baggers i mean you go back and you
look at what happened to gold stocks in
the latter part of the 1970s early 1980s
that's what happened
right and and so i expect
something similar i mean maybe it won't
be as meteoric as what happened with
bitcoin uh it's hard to repeat that
uh but i think it's gonna be big and i
have a lot of real money in this trade i
mean i think most the people that got
into bitcoin when it was you know a
dollar or ten dollars you know they
didn't put that much money in maybe a
few people did but most people didn't
put much so i've got a big bet riding on
on on these mining stocks a much bigger
bet than i ever would have made on
crypto even if i made the bet do you own
anything
peter peters
do you only like bitcoin you know i
don't own any bitcoin why would i be
dumb enough to buy bitcoin well because
bitcoins up 212 percent over the last
two years and gold's only up five which
means gold hasn't outperformed inflation
and bitcoin outperformed your whole
portfolio that'd be one reason well it
hasn't outperformed it year to date it
hasn't outperformed it in the last year
i mean bitcoin in november of last year
was almost 70 000 and now it's barely 30
thousand i mean gold doesn't do that
gold doesn't drop by 50 60 percent
because it doesn't go up 50 or 60 either
well yes it does i just told you 20
years ago it was under 300. 20 years ago
i don't even think i knew how to read
yet that's the point you should listen
to people who were around back then you
know the world existed you know when you
were still in diapers or before you were
born so i got some gray hairs if you
haven't noticed so i've been around the
block a few times you you also have
dial-up wi-fi it looks like but i won't
go say nothing about that dial up
internet